after one of the most intense
Bachelorette finales in the show's
history runner-up Peter Krause will not
be the bachelor fans were shocked and
wanted answers only et is sitting down
with the Wisconsin native for his first
interview since the announcement my
friends I'm very glad you're here a lot
of fans were blindsided by the fact that
you are not The Bachelor
however the past couple weeks been for
you a lot of ups and downs were you
blindsided I know I wouldn't say so I
have my reasons for wanting to or not
wanting to do the show and I'm happy
with things right now I guess that's way
to put it because it was such an
emotional roller coaster I didn't feel
like I had enough time to truly process
the seasons and after the final rose
I needed more time for clarity I'm type
person who needs maybe too much time to
process things when they come to life
and love not necessarily business when
it comes to business I move quickly but
in the bigger picture when I talk about
my wife and my future I want to take
time to really think about it you wrote
on social media about not letting fear
guide your decisions yeah what did that
mean so fear came from other people's
opinions which I I don't know if I
should guy my life on that but I do take
what people say very very personally I
was afraid of what people would say
I was afraid of what people would think
I was afraid of not being able to live
up to the amazing standards that are the
lead of that position what a lot of
people have said is why go on the show
if you didn't think you could propose
what do you think of those people there
is nowhere in the contract where it says
you have to get engaged at 2:00 in the
show I want if I love my life and if it
was an opportunity to have some fun get
some experiences and potentially find
love I was open for it
I made the mistake maybe of not watching
Rachel prior to the show and seeing that
she wanted an engagement more so than
what I was ready to give it that time I
guess and the reason I didn't watch
anything going into it was I wanted to
know nothing about Rachel so as organic
as possible he's dating something that's
on your mind dating I'm sure will be
interesting moving forward from here I
got my dog at this point she keeps me
very happy
so we're hanging out and just staying on
the sidelines of that for now now you're
focused on your business worth personal
training why is it so important to you
people all have their own stories
everybody needs to find their own level
for it and if you're happy or unhappy in
your life the way for you to get to that
next stage no matter what is always
different than mine so I want people to
find their own abilities their own
talents their own worth
through my god it's my trainers guns our
help could you see yourself being the
bachelor in the future is that door open
if the offer were to come up again in
the future I could see myself doing it
seems like an amazing opportunity I'm
single I'm happy business is good family
is good I'm ready for the next step
again and if that's what route it took I
be ok with that
[Music]